arguably one of the greatest boxers of
all time Floyd Mayweather may fight
arguably one of the greatest UFC
fighters in the history of the franchise
Conor McGregor and everyone's talking
about a boxer a classic boxer versus UFC
fighter would they fight in the Octagon
with a fight in the ring do you think
that's gonna happen I do I do think it's
gonna I think it's gonna be a tough deal
because obviously a lot of egos involved
in this deal and a lot of people so that
always makes it tougher but on the flip
side there's so much money involved I
just don't see how it doesn't happen and
you know everybody always asks and it
would be boxing it wouldn't be see
that's the thing it's through the rules
would be strictly boxing Conor can't use
any of the I mean UFC obviously right
you can use all of your body
there'll be no elbows no just
straight-up boxing in a boxing ring with
with gloves and the whole deal and you
know what a lot of things make this
fight intriguing but the reality is this
anybody's ever seen Floyd Mayweather
you've seen him right yeah he's this big
okay he's that tall and that's not
really true that's really that's the
size of a small refrigerator you're
describing anyway yes sorry McGregor is
huge and you know he's 27 years old he's
in the prime of his career Floyd is 40
Floyd always had problems with south
pause Connor is a southpaw and Connor
hits hard when he hits people they go
Floyd is definitely not knocking him out
that's for sure so it's an it I'm not
saying that Connor would win this boxing
match but it sure makes it interesting I
one of the reasons I would want to to
ninis to see Floyd Mayweather kick
don't you think Floyd should be kicking
and this or why not just open it up and
they both have pool noodles I mean why
not why not just go nuts with this and
really add everything you can think of
well that's the thing I mean if this was
a mixed martial arts fight it wouldn't
last thirty seconds I mean Connor Connor
would destroy him I could say Connor I
think as Connor I'm a lot taller than
Connor you're a lot taller than a lot of
people yeah yeah
and the taller guy is always the better
fighter well that's it for my list of
lies tonight
you